ou est-ce que vous avez des complexes
oui géraldine c'était pareil bah moi à
oui mesurer combien déjà gg 1 m 82 ans
cinquième bassin en fait je connais ça
normalement quand tu arrives tu amènes
est amène sans rien et amène la photo de
classe à tes parents ils font ce qu'ils
veulent c'est la pauvre est toujours tu
vois pas et comme la meuf la plus grande
de l'est il ya toujours une meuf qui est
très grande joie car elle est toujours à
côté de la prof sur le côté normand sur
le côté gauche baal elle est comme à
elle met des jupes longues mon frère
normalement c'est stéphanie gravier ou
corrélées 1 m 80 dans ça peut pas la
draguer mettrait à prendre c'est un truc
de ouf ça veut dire qu'elle est ce qu il
était commandant mais se fait draguer
par des garçons qui sont beaucoup
partagé on voulait pas parce que vous
êtes totalement jeune et immature voile
et la houlala ce que ce que j'aime chez
clara luciani c'est que là où on voit
maintenant qu'à lesquelles elle est
passée outre elle a totalement assumé
c'est que maintenant elle mets des
talons alors mon truc c'est quand je
mettais des talons quand j'ai compris
que je peux y mettre des talons je
venais de mettre 22 je me suis lassé
monte à passer le cap en face c'est bon
ben ok c'est bon c'est bon j'ai bien
compris que c'était quoi votre complexe
moi j'ai un complexe de supériorité par
rapport à jean michel plus je le
fréquente plus je me trouve intelligent
bas en comparaison
bah je comprends mais c'est super dur
combat j'étais en pension très vite 14
ans et complet déjà je n'ai jamais été
très très très mec se mettait deux
t-shirts l'un sur deux pour essayer de
trouver 50 km 85 et du coup en pension
comme avait beaucoup de gens comme vous
et inculte et violent
[Rires]
s'il te plaît et c'est quoi ça t'a pas
gratuite qui migrent au pouce mais aussi
parce que je pense que c'est j'en ai
marre parce que je me fais agresser
c'est le pire est du coup je faisais res
et c'est pas beau ça avait du jus quand
pension du coup je faisais les devoirs
de 2,3 comme vous de trois molosses et
george gillett devoirs et eu du coup me
protéger non mais si à la cantine dans
les vestiaires partout parce que sinon
je faisais et rappelle à nous alors ça
c'est horrible je rigole pas avec ça
mais c'est vrai il ya plein de gens qui
nous regardent si c'est non mais c'est
vrai mais le complexe et c'était tout
maigrichon